but to put the national spotlight on  Chicago for something that is both  egregious and untrue is simply shameful  I'm also concerned about what this means  moving forward to hit crimes now of  course the Chicago Police Department  would continue to investigate all  reports of these types of incidents with  the same amount of vigor that we did  with this one but my concern is that  hate crimes were now publicly be met  with a level of skepticism that  previously didn't happen  that said smollett was treated as a  victim throughout this investigation  until we receive evidence that led  detectives in another direction